- [Man] What you're seeing
was built by one man
pebble by pebble, over 33 years.
One morning, mailman Ferdinand
Cheval stumbled across
an interesting looking
stone on his delivery route.
He picked it up, and from
there, an obsession began.
Using stones he collected on his walk,
Cheval worked each night
without any formal training
to build what is now
called the Palais Idéal.
The final structure is 85
feet long and 300 feet high.
It mingles Chinese, Algerian,
and Northern European
influences to create a fantastic
and completely original
castle of grottos.
He opened the palace in 1870
for the public to enjoy.
In his own words he says,
"You start wondering if you
have not been carried away
into a fantastic dream, with boundaries
beyond the scope of imagination."
And this incredible,
bizarre, and unique place
does look like something you
could only see in a dream.